the last stand is not as fast paced as
the trailer might lead you to believe if
you haven't seen the trailer go watch my
trailer review it can use some hits
seriously but that doesn't mean it's a
boring film it's surprisingly serious at
times too sometimes those serious
moments actually hit more often they're
not they're actually very cheesy but
let's get to the good stuff is Arnold
back [ __ ] yeah he's back I enjoy old
Arnold not much different from younger
Arnold but Matt is that guy good at
parodying himself the film never has a
dull moment it's got two great villains
a lot of fun supporting characters that
really helped elevate this movie but
most importantly this film is a lot of
fun it's really telling two stories that
bill to a climactic 30-minute finale and
when it gets to that finale you'll be
satisfied unless you're an annoying
douchebag who's like that's not art it's
not supposed to be it's supposed to be
fun cheesy escapism and it does a good
job at doing just that you'll laugh
you'll go oh you'll have a good time
Ryan Wright says the last stack got it
right
you